why do you think it's so important for
so many filmmakers
to make that first feature film by 30.
that's a fantastic question
um by
30 uh i i think it's
you know your 20s are about sort of
figuring out who you are
and a lot of trial and error and a lot
of like messing up and
when you hit your 30s you sort of have
that feeling like you have to have it
all together
right like you're an adult now you're an
official adult
you're not in the 20s like put all that
you know childish stuff behind
you're in the 30s you're you're thinking
about building a family
and and doing all of that and you're
really thinking about
your career and and sort of you know
how you advance in that whatever it may
be day job
you know or filmmaking um and so i think
it's that that
pressure of of turning 30 and feeling
like you need to become
a full adult that pushes people to go
well i need to do a feature now
um and i think you know you know some
people may be ready for that just as
developmentally some people you know are
still going to be
tooling around and you know doing all
this club life and dating
and stuff in their 30s which you know
you can do or should do or have to do
you know depending on your situation
or situations yeah but they could be in
their 60s doing that
exactly yeah it really just does depend
on the person
yeah i think a lot of it well it seems
like it comes from family pressure
or that traditional sort of idea and
people don't want to let their
their family unit down and some people
don't have that
and they have a like maybe they wish
they had it
because they're so carefree yeah so i
think there's two two sides of the coin
and i've seen a lot of people that
come from very close-knit families where
you know they really want their kids to
succeed
yeah but then there is that pressure
like you've got to grow up by 30.
sure so i think when you're creative it
might be tricky because you want to
please the people that you love but at
the same time
you're still an artist in some way yeah
do that
so you've managed to do both you've done
a lot of short films
you've made a feature and you said that
you were
paying for sometimes you know you would
like 15 hour days
yeah back when i first moved out to los
angeles
um i i didn't go to film school
i went to a journalism school in des
moines iowa where i
was a part of the radio and tv
production program so i learned a lot
technically
you know but what i didn't learn was how
to like make films
or how to tell stories you know um
in that regard so what i knew that i
needed once i moved out to la was like
real on-set experience like how is a
movie set run
what makes you know a good movie set
what makes a bad movie set in terms of
operating it because
if i'm going to be running this one day
i need to know what styles of work
i like what styles of work i don't and
when you start at the very bottom
and you sort of see everything from that
low position
and you see how like people are are
treated and you know you have those eyes
into everything
um i think it's a really good look and
it was for me
about like how i want my sets to run and
the one set
that i worked on which really
set a high example of like what an
amazing film set
is is uh when i worked on a serious man
the coen brothers movie great yeah it
was uh it was filming back in minnesota
and i was like this is an amazing
opportunity i will
uh i got to get on this set right so i
found a way to connect to the aeds and i
told them i was like
like i know you may need pas from out
there i will i'm from there i'm from
minnesota i will move back there
for you know while it's being shot you
don't have to put me up you don't have
to do anything like
just let me work on a coen brothers set
yeah and
they're like cool come on board so i did
it
i spent a month out there and
just being able to like see how the
cohen's worked
and just i mean seeing roger deakins
work for one was just
amazing but um being able to
to see how respectful everybody was
how nobody yelled how quiet the set was
um how everybody did their jobs and like
was very it was a very you know familial
feeling set um it was really
just eye-opening because you've been you
know i at least have been
on those sets of low-budget things and
like hallmark movies and big movies you
know
all in between in tv shows and you you
see like
the tensions and the stress and the
yelling and the screaming and the
disrespect like you see all of that
um and the cohen's like on a serious man
they had
none of that like it was the smoothest
running set
um everybody was really on board and it
was it was a pleasure to be on
how cool yeah so sorry you were in l.a
and then you thought well let me go back
please
please let me be on the set and you went
there was no other way i was going to be
able to get on that set it's like
i had to sacrifice i had to be like you
know i will fly myself out there i'll
stay at my parents house
it'll be fun to see everybody again you
know but just
let me work on this movie please and so
did you stay
at your parents house i did yeah yeah so
what time would you leave to go to set
that's so
oh man i would i would leave i would say
around like five a.m
to get to set around like 5 36 because
the pas are like the first on set
you know first on set last leave so yeah
you know just sort of driving through
the night and getting to whatever
location whether it's you know
the suburban street that the family
lived on
or you know the park where they're down
by the lake like
it was it was fun you know and allowed
me to see
a different part of minnesota and the
place that i grew up
than i would have otherwise and you know
you realize like oh yeah there's this
whole
strip of a neighborhood that has you
know houses that were just
still they lit still look like they're
from like that era you know like the 60s
the 70s like
it's really trippy and it really opens
your eyes about like what is around
you know what's available sort of you
know in your hometown
and how was it to see the actors between
takes because that's where like
the first i think the first set i was on
was melrose place
back i mean like well aren't there two
of them they're the first one the 90s
one
yeah and for me seeing like what it was
actually like
seeing them turn the camera okay let's
try another angle how was that for you
um it was cool when i could see it you
know because as a pa
sometimes you don't necessarily get to
be like that close to set
sometimes you're stuck way out you know
like blocking traffic or making sure you
know that people don't you know
invade the set or whatever but when i
got to sort of see
uh you know like some of the smaller
scenes
you know with the actors it was it was
really cool to see
you know how how excited everybody was
to be there and
like how the cohen's worked with
everybody and you know how
easy it sort of seemed that's that's
what was interesting is like
for me working with actors especially
established
actors you know as somebody who hasn't
you know done that many
films it's uh it's a little you know
freaky you know you're like you've done
a lot and what have i done
so it's a little intimidating and uh
but they made it seem so easy which is
like that's sort of what i want to
strive for
so when you wrapped how was it you you
had to fly back to la
yeah yeah yeah so i spent about a month
um
home and then my time was done i was
like alright well back to la to try to
find the next job you know
because that's what it is when you're a
pa it's like it's making those
connections on set
and trying to get work and like pinging
those connections when you're out of
work and
trying to figure out what to do so it's
it's a really terrifying thing that i
i'm glad i did when i was young and i
sort of didn't know any better
and i was just full of this head of
steam of like all right like i'm gonna
make this happen no matter what
and you just sort of because you're
fearless in that regard you know even
though you're full of fear which is an
interesting dichotomy like
you're just going for it because you
have to survive
one like survival instincts are in and
you know very active because
you got to make rent you got to be able
to eat you know
so getting that work you know
is sort of a you know life or death type
thing
you